I think there's something cathartic
about watching films together but you'd
be mine anything to do with laughter or
scares or romance you are much better
served in a collective environment it's
almost contagious if people scream you
get into the vibe ghosts are very scary
in this film but the people are almost
scarier Edith this is my sister a house
as old as this one becomes in time the
living thing I like to see my movies in
a theater because I like the community
experience I like going to a comedy and
laughing at the same time with a hundred
other strangers for a movie like crimson
peak where the adrenaline is really
rushing maybe someone screams you really
feel like you're on this rollercoaster
ride has anyone died in this house
specific deaths violent deaths there are
some really good scarce in the morning I
particularly loved as seen in a corridor
with two ghosts you know I think is
really really good what do you want
people still love to get together and
turn the lights out and watch something
as a group and I think that's because we
find connection in responding to the
same thing whether if it's a comedy we
laugh together if it's a spooky film
like crimson peak we gasp together and I
think there's something really fun about
the last 20 minutes of the film is a lot
of tension in it I'm really excited to
see that with an audience it's
unrelenting this is the kind of film
that if you can experience it in its
most immersive way it'll be incredibly
powerful the great thing about imax is
you really feel like you're part of the
experience it's not really watching a
film you're experiencing the film
you